welcome to CBS this morning but of
course we're going to begin with that
debate the top Democratic candidates for
president had their most brutal and
brutal is a word encounter of the
campaign last night in Las Vegas
contenders brought new urgency to the
NBC News debate and the new man on stage
Mike Bloomberg was the biggest target
the billionaire ex Republican was
grilled on his record as New York's
mayor and his behavior as a business
leader some of his answers brought even
more criticism Nikole Killion is in Las
Vegas she covered the debate Nicole what
are we hearing from Bloomberg's campaign
in the aftermath of the debate well
Anthony some of Bloomberg's aides admit
it wasn't his strongest showing
considering this was his first debate
and about a decade but overall the
campaign is pleased with his performance
and said he's just warming up I'd like
to talk about who we're running against
a billionaire who calls women fat broads
and horse-faced lesbians and no I'm not
talking about Donald Trump I'm talking
about Mayor Bloomberg fight night in
Vegas started in the opening round with
Michael Bloomberg in the center of the
Ring I don't think you look at Donald
Trump and say we need someone richer in
the White House mr. Bloomberg had
policies in New York City of
stop-and-frisk
which went after african-american and
Latino people in an outrageous way the
former New York City Mayor said he was
embarrassed about the outcome of the
controversial policing policies it got
out of control and when we discovered I
discovered that we were doing many many
too many stop and frisks we cut 95% of
it how was a bad idea after we sent in
monitors and said it must stop even then
he continued the policy Bloomberg who
has largely averted face to face
scrutiny was also asked about
allegations of sexual harassment at his
company I have no tolerance for the kind
of behavior that the me2 movement
movement has exposed in my company lots
and lots of women have big
responsibilities they have paid exactly
the same as men I hope you've heard what
his defense was I'd been nice to some
women and was pressed about whether he
would release former employees from
Dundas
closure agreements have a very few
non-disclosure agreements how many a
finish how many is there none of them
accuse me of doing anything other than
maybe they didn't like the joke I told
and let me just put and let me put
theirs would be agreements between two
parties that wanted to keep it quiet you
could release them from that immediately
because understand this is not just a
question of the mayor's character this
is also a question about electability we
are not going to be Donald Trump with a
man who has who knows how many
non-disclosure agreements and the drip
drip drip of stories of women saying
they have been harassed and
discriminated against Bloomberg also
dueled with current frontrunner Bernie
Sanders socialists in the country
happens to be a millionaire with three
houses what I miss here
well you miss that I work in Washington
house watch the first problem live in
Burlington house - that's good and like
thousands of other poor markets I do
have a summer camp forgive me for that
where is your home which tax which tax
haven new york new york city former
South Bend mayor Pete Buddha judge
pitched himself as the moderate choice
we shouldn't have to choose between one
candidate who wants to burn this party
down and another candidate who wants to
buy this party out senator Elizabeth
Warren had the most speaking time last
night with her fiery attacks on all of
the candidates her campaign said she had
the best debate day of her campaign
raising more than two and a half million
dollars Gail that's what you call a good
night for Elizabeth Warren Nicole thank
you very much